what do you think of the president today
saying that he wants to dedicate himself
to trying to make progress on gun
control well he hasn't been able to make
progress for his entire administration
and frankly uh I'm very thankful for
that
the fact that he's been frustrated on
his objectives of more gun control is
something that I'm happy about I mean
this is something you had Piers Morgan
there many non Americans have a problem
with it seems that there is a simple
equation which is more guns in America
and more gun deaths as a consequence now
that's absolutely not true
the the FBI statistics just you know
every year the Uniform Crime reports
that come out we'll talk about so-called
assault weapons according to the FBI
more people were killed with blunt
objects in the most recent year that
figures are available than were shot
with all types of long guns meaning a
shotgun or a rifle or a so-called
assault weapon there is not an epidemic
that people like tears would like people
to believe the statistics that are used
to prop up such false narratives come
from gun control groups that have a
well-documented history of
misrepresenting the facts or oftentimes
outright lying does that mean you would
support a ban or controls on handguns
absolutely not because your statistic is
leaving out handguns if you included old
firearms you would have many more deaths
by firearms well the vast majority of
firearms deaths believe it's nineteen
thousand or so give or take our suicides
while those incidents are tragic I have
yet to hear a single gun control
supporter explain
why that is the business of the entire
country as opposed to just the person's
family
and their immediate close friends and
relatives why are we talking about
punishing
hundreds of millions of people because
of people committing suicide
well Piers Morgan was quoting a figure
that since 9/11 they've been approaching
400,000 deaths by firearms of one kind
and another whereas America's decided to
ban chocolate eggs with toys inside them
because they're a danger to health there
does seem to be a slight inconsistency
there I wish I had a chance to debate
tears again in a longer format because
that reference to the kinder egg was a
complete red herring and I believe he
knows that and this is another typical
example of anti-gun propaganda they use
the biggest number they can four hundred
thousand over 15 years gives a false
impression of this huge problem when
there really isn't one it's the same
reason that they lump suicides criminal
shootings police shootings and lawful
self-defense all into one big number two
may give a false impression it's the
same reason why the gun control groups
have stopped talking about just deaths
and now they use the much bigger number
of injuries and deaths again to feed
into that false narrative that they want
to to push I think the issue is that
proportionately in America more people
die died by firearms than they do in
other countries and what you appear to
be saying is so what that's a price
worth paying
no I would say that according to a UN
report the United States ranks one
hundred and eleventh in the world for
per capita gun violence four are far
below many other other countries that
have complete gun bans or almost
complete gun bans the issue in the
United States number one I don't know
any I will say this I don't know anybody
that cares if two drug-dealing criminals
kill each other in a shootout good we
the taxpayers don't have to pay to keep
them locked up in jail so be it they're
criminals as the suicide issue is tragic
I already said that I still don't have
yet to hear a reasonable
explanation for why the method that
someone uses to commit suicide should
have an effect on someone else's
enumerated protective didn't worry I
just wanna ask you finally you've made a
point of introducing and showing videos
of you introducing your young daughter
to firearms why have you done that sorry
could you say that again yeah you've
made a point of going public about
introducing your young daughter to
firearms well why have you done that oh
she went public herself when she
testified before a state legislative
committee and she's also a a nationally
sponsored competitive athlete I mean she
has a story to tell like anybody else
does and you think it's a good thing
she's familiar with firearms
oh absolutely do i I was an instructor
since before my children were born I am
convinced beyond any doubt that the best
way to avoid accidents with children and
firearms which by the way the CDC
recently removed from the top ten list
of childhood mortality rates but the
best way to avoid accidents is to have
educated children that aren't curious
about a gun that know that there are not
toys that know they have to be respected
and they know how to handle them or what
to do or what not to do if they come
across one ignorant is what causes
accidents and deaths
mr. Roberts thank you for joining us